massive series of studies was done where
they found that for decades we've been
living longer obviously because of
advances in medicine and technology but
that reversed it started reversing in 96
by 2014 it was an established reversal
it's called death of this categorizes
deaths of despair so essentially people
are dying eight to 25 years younger and
they should now in this modern age
it's two years added to this with a
pandemic
from preventable lifestyle issues so
people dying younger and gen z
is the most medicated generation ever in
history and they are the most risk of
dying 8 to 25 years younger which is
terrible and it's our fault as adults as
as leaders as whatever because our
generation has adopted the last 40 years
has totally messed this up
welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
episode 113 with dr caroline leaf
this was one of my favorite podcasts on
brain plasticity
caroline is brilliant i managed to get
off of psych meds myself and heal with
diet but part of what i did was change
my response to stimuli
that happened somewhat naturally due to
dietary change but dr leaf a
communication pathologist and cognitive
neuroscientist actually explained what
happened to me when i healed from major
depressive disorder she helps people
understand their minds and change their
lives for the better dr leaf is the
best-selling author of switch on your
brain think learn succeed think and eat
yourself smart and her most recent
cleaning up your mental mess five simple
scientifically proven steps to reduce
anxiety stress and toxic thinking this
stuff works she has papers and brain
scans showing how to reduce anxiety and
toxic brain pathways and grow new ways
of thinking cutting edge crazy
interesting stuff enjoy this episode if
you like it remember to hit subscribe
[Music]
dr caroline leaf welcome to my podcast
thank you so good to be with you
michaela
i'm really looking forward to this i've
been following you work for a while i've
been very interested in
trauma and how to get rid of it and what
the state of your mind can do to your
overall health
and
you cover that a lot in
your recent book yeah
so
i guess well we should just start with
um for anyone who doesn't know you can
you give a bit of a brief background
about who you are and what it is you do
absolutely well i'm a cognitive and
clinical neuroscientist and
communication pathologist and that's a
big mouthful for
someone who works with the mind brain
body connection so i've been trained in
a very interesting way i've done all the
psychology and i've done medicine and
it's sort of a mixture of psychology
medicine neuropsychology neuroscience
communication there's a specialized
degree that they did for a period of
time and i tell you this to say that
my training was very unique and and when
i was doing it i thought gosh why am i
doing this because it was so hard but
i'm so glad because it forced me to
understand an area that is one of the
most
um badly researched areas in my opinion
in the world of science and we see the
impact today in the current medical the
psychiatric movement which you and i
were briefly discussing in the just
before we started so basically what i do
is i look at people's how they
functioning how they're showing up what
what are they saying what are they doing
what are the behaviors what are the
emotions what are the mindsets what's
happening there because that's not who
they are that's evidence that there's
something going on in their life
and that's that principle then it
teaches you to be what i'd call a
thought detective where you can actually
say okay these are my patterns
and why am i doing this and because
that's not actually how i'm wired
because we literally are wired our
psychoneurobiologies wired for for love
literally for survival and then to track
back and find out the thoughts behind
that and then the thinking process that
built the thought in the first place
right down to the root or the origin so
if someone's showing up with major
emotional um things like depression and
conformal relationship and whatever
these
you take that back from that pattern all
the way back down to the root which
could be traumatic child abuse or some
kind of trauma in childhood or early
early adulthood or whatever so
everything has a root and what we see
from brain science is that you can't
just slap a band-aid on a bullet wound
you can't just
suppress something or do a few
techniques or a bit of meditation or a
bit of breathing which are all important
but all they do is prepare the brain
they don't rewire the brain and they
don't change the brain so i wanted to
understand the principle of rewiring the
brain which is neuroplasticity and how
long it takes and what do you do and
what is doing the rewiring and that's
the mind so the i did a lot of work on
the mind brain separation what are the
differences between the mind and the
brain and how can we control the brain
and how can we direct the
neuroplasticity in the brain so that's
kind of a summary and i started off in
the world very therapeutic world of
working with traumatic brain injury and
alzheimer's and traumas and you know
headache traumas water with sexual
trauma learning disabilities um autism
that sort of thing and they very soon
saw that i needed to develop systems
that would help people to you know
manage their minds to change their brain
because people were just kind of doing
therapy getting stuck you know not
really moving forward and i wanted to
change that and then that's why i
developed theories and systems and i've
continued over these years to do
clinical research and make this
available to everyone because we all
have a mind we all have a brain and we
all need to manage it daily so that's
kind of a big big picture overview of
what i did i don't practice anymore i
practiced for 25 years as a clinical
neuroscientist now what i do is i
continue my research and everything i do
and have learned i put into books and
materials and i have an app and that
kind of thing to try and help people
manage their mind
okay so
let me see where do i want to start that
was a lot of information it was
i that was good though
i think well might as well start where i
want to which is
how long does it take to change your
brain
that's an excellent question so if i may
preface that with
um with just the mind brain separation
and then we can just in terms of the
time because i think that's quite
important we live in a day in an age
where the mind and the brain are used
interchangeably so i've got a couple of
props so for those that are listening
i'm holding up a model brain in in the
skull and we've advanced traumatically
in since the mid-90s to now about
understanding the neuroscience of the
brain which is amazing but on the
negative side it's made um the
philosophy of mind very neurocentric so
people are all about brain brain brain
so it's my brain make me do it my
brain's broken my brain is diseased i'm
depressed because i've got a brain
disease yeah you familiar with that
language okay so yes
and it's very unfortunate because 38
years ago when i started in this field
mind and brain was seen as separate but
interchangeable so mind drove brain
brain was physical mind is this force
that drives the brain it's your ability
to to think feel and choose and when you
dance you don't think feel and choose
and so your brain doesn't do anything
but they didn't believe the brain could
change in the early 80s so i did some of
the first interesting super interesting
so they understood mind brain but they
didn't believe the brain could change so
i challenged that and did some of the
first neuroplasticity research in the
early 90s showing that people with
traumatic brain injuries can if they use
their mind which they can then change
their brain and i showed that i showed
the 35 to 75 improvements in cognitive
emotional social function changes in the
brain everything and that kind of
launched me online into my career that
i've that i've been in for the last
traumatic brain injury from that and
learning disabilities and emotional
traumas and alzheimer's dementias we are
still also in dementia i worked with
those as well and autism and all those
things so essentially mind is how you
mind is what we're using now to be able
to talk to each other it's your ability
to listen to me process what i'm saying
think feel and choose you're pushing
that in your brain and you make you
growing you're converting what i'm
saying into little trees in your brain
that literally look like like this
you're building thought trees in your
brain and that enables you to then
process what i'm saying i will apply and
then talk about it that's what we're
doing all day long so mind is the force
that's the first cause if you did if you
and i were dead we couldn't have this
conversation we wouldn't see any changes
in the brain but because we are talking
i've i linked you and i up to various
different types of brain technology that
i use in my research we would see
massive activity in your brain we'd see
growth and change and so on so mind is
the force that creates the change mind
is the force that drives the
neuroplasticity and mind is you you and
me your ability to think feel and choose
your ability to be human to experience
life to process life that's the
psychological and then on a physics
level it's gravitational fields and
electromagnetic forces and so if i put a
qeg on your brain
right now we would see a lot of energy
response but if i put it on a dead brain
we would see no energy response so the
mind is taking what we're saying it's
all psychology stuff of understanding
what we're saying things will choose but
there's also this force that gets pushed
through the brain mind gets pushed
through the brain the brain responds
electromagnetically and chemically
involves thoughts so that's the basic
fundamental process that's
neuroplasticity it's driven by mind it's
happening all the time your mind never
stops you can go three weeks without
food three days without water three
minutes without oxygen but you can't
even go three seconds without your mind
stopping your mind never stops so your
mind is awake when you're awake it's
awake when you're asleep it just never
stops it's what you eat with it drives
your digestive system it drives your
dreams every single thing is mind-driven
so essentially our mind is kind of messy
because we don't really we constantly
hypothesizing we like little scientists
we don't know what's going on the events
the circum so sometimes we you know we
respond well sometimes we don't respond
well so it's a whole hits and miss
situation and we that's okay us our
psycho neurobiology our mind brain body
um can handle that what we can't handle
is not managing the mess so when we make
a mess like let's say we get irritated
because someone cuts in front of us in
traffic or something that's okay it's
frustrating
and that's okay to be messy to get
irritated and maybe shout scream sway
whatever but you don't want to stay
there because the disruption and this
regulation that that creates this is a
very simple example and i'll take it to
a more complex one in a moment but
that's regulation creates a pattern in
the brain that if you don't stabilize it
um it will then get become a toxic
something toxic and then so the protein
structures change and you get this
downstream effect into your body you
know the mind brain body connection we
actually
sorry and i really don't mean to
interrupt no no you actually get into
that a little bit maybe after like what
happens when you're in
like a chronic stress or something okay
i'm gonna do that i'll explain that with
some really simple examples
and then we'll and i'll talk quickly
about should i quickly finish about this
in the in the 60s
and then we'll come back that's a really
it's an excellent example and i'm glad
we're going to go there um so
essentially that this regulation happens
and if you don't manage that mess and it
accumulates and you keep getting messy
and you just stay messy the whole day in
your whole life and you just just keep
complaining and angry and frustrated
eventually just accumulates and you have
a lot of toxicity in your brain and
instead of building a healthy thought
which is the green tree i'm holding up
you actually build a toxic thought
so if you don't manage your mess this
toxic thought becomes established and
when it becomes established it's an
actual physical protein structure much
like the covert virus or any bacteria
which are physical viruses which are
physical things in your brain and this
creates terrible disturbance in the
brain and the body the immune system
wants to fight it and all kinds of stuff
so this is how do you know i'm sorry
again but how do you know that it isn't
that that's causing the behavior how do
you know that it's this it is this so so
therefore these two okay so there's two
parts here so
the excellent question
so
here and next we in here we are in life
we drive in the car the irritation
happens there's a response so it wasn't
there before you have the response you
get irritated yeah this builds in the
brain if you manage it it goes away
and you it's gone and it's done and
you've got through you've said okay well
i got irritated it's okay i'm gonna calm
down i'm gonna keep driving let that
person cut in whatever whatever you do
to just get yourself a and that's a
simple example but let's say now that
you in childhood you got abused or
you're bullied at school or you're in
the workplace and you're being bullied
or whatever the millions of things that
can go wrong in life which do
each of those is experience of you in
life you're processing that experience
through your mind into your brain and
you're growing these trees now for those
of you that are watching are listening
i'm holding up a toxic tree any tree has
roots
so if you plant a tree it's got a seed
and then there's roots and then there's
a tree trunk and then there's branches
that's exactly what happens with the
thought so if you have an established
trauma things that are going wrong or
cumulatively going wrong over life every
experience grows like this it's a as the
experience starts that's the seed then
as
the this experience is happening the
emotions the physical whatever whatever
all the detail of the experience the
email the toxic words the toxic people
what's being said what's being done all
of that is building into the root system
that's the origin now that immediately
gets processed there's a tree trunk and
it's all distorted and twisted so
because this is distorted incoming
information the interpretation we make
is distorted so we think feel and choose
about that in a distorted way then we
build these branches which is above the
ground the branches are then our coating
mechanism the trauma responses the think
feel chews details emotions that kind of
stuff of what we've experienced so when
that happens this thing is a whole
thought structure it's protein it's got
energy it's generating energy this then
produces our behaviors and this comes
full circle back to what i said in the
beginning i trained people to be thought
detectives to look at and this answers
your question your patterns and
behaviors are hear what you're doing
saying feeling etc and from those those
that can come from fresh air they've
come from these so these produce the
behaviors so when you look at our
patterns and if there's existing
patterns and we get triggered so we
don't deal with the stuff it goes back
down in an unconscious even stronger
than before you get into a situation
someone says something boom that's
triggered now there's it's triggered and
now what's happening is added to the
roots and into the system and then it's
reinforced it gets even stronger and the
behavior that this produces
um is going to be even more toxic and
then you suppress it you don't deal with
it and so the thing goes on eventually
these are like volcanoes they explode
and that explodes in your mind your
brain your body and in multitude of
different ways we're all unique there's
no cookie cutter if this happens that
happens it's just a whole bunch of stuff
that happens and we then we've got to
kind of deal with that and you can i
mean you can rewire that too because we
have volcanoes all the time happening
it's just the nature of life what i'm
trying to teach people to do is
understand the process and recognize
it's okay to have a volcano it's not the
best thing but it's okay you can still
repair a volcano and when the volcano
stops firing eventually the grass that
grows over the area of the volcano is
healthier than before because of the
minerals from the volcano so you can
transform this so you can't change
what's happened to you but you can
change what's in you and that's the
process of neuroplasticity and your
question about how long that takes how
long is it going to find the pattern
find the thinking the thought find the
thinking pattern find the root
deconstruct reconstruct into a healthy
version that process takes cycles of 63
days
so and it works in groups of 21. so
there's been a lot of misinformation out
there that it takes 21 days to form a
habit it doesn't take 21
it takes 63. we have changes happening
every 21 the first 21 is generally where
we become aware of our patterns and we
start becoming a thought detective and
we start seeing the the data the
emotions and the how you think feel and
choose about yourself the coping
mechanisms the trauma responses and you
start seeing the roots so it takes about
21 days to do that kind of
deconstruction but by the end of 21 days
you have built a reconceptualized new
thought it's changed i'm holding up the
green tree and i'm going to pull a
little piece of the green tree out
there's a teeny little piece so this
ugly toxic tree has now been changed
deconstructed and reconstructed into
what you want it's still part of you
you're still sad it still happened but
you've changed how it's playing out into
your future so yes that happened but
but that takes about 21 days around
about
then this is still tiny and here's where
the other two cycles come in this is
where people get stuck people stop
people get okay i've done the work i
know why i'm traumatized i know why i
did this in my life i know where the
depression is coming from or whatever
but then they get stuck here because
they haven't stabilized a new pattern of
thinking so that takes another 42 days
to change behavior to have
the feeling that i know what to do but i
can't do it or i'm stuck i'm going you
know i can't do this and i feel even
more guilty to stop and avoid that and
to make this strong think of it as a
teeny little plant that you have to
water and make it nice and strong that
takes another two cycles of 21 days of
daily consistently practicing the new
way of thinking and as you're practicing
that in a simple little five-minute
process you get tremendous insight so
you gain every few days you gain
tremendous insight and as each time you
get insight you are changing the
structure of this little tree this
thought tree is becoming stronger and
stronger and stronger and eventually
you'll be in a situation where you
triggered but this comes up not the old
pattern and you'll remember oh i used to
do that but now i'm doing this doesn't
mean you're not going to have depression
and anxiety because those aren't
illnesses those are totally normal human
responses they're warning signals
they're not brain diseases like we've
been told they're not brain deceit you
can't be depressed you can't be
depression you can't as much as you
can't be anger as much as you can't be
frustration
anger depression frustration they're all
the same category
of warning signals telling us there's
something going on there's a reason why
and that's so yeah yeah it's so freeing
to have people understand this episode
is brought to you by true local we're
talking about brain health so why not
true local partners with local farmers
and butchers in your area to source high
quality meat and deliver it to your door
100 grass-fed and grass-finished beef
pasture-raised chicken lamb bison and
more i recommend they're grain-fed beef
i think it tastes better although their
grass-fed beef is good
wild salmon and their lamb is some of
the best i've ever had they have over
100 different cuts of meat that you
probably can't find at your grocery
store liver if you're into that to get
started just go to tru
local.ca for canadians or
trulocalusa.com for americans to build
your own personalized box of meat shows
up at your door vacuum sealed and
individually portioned which is perfect
for meal prep and planning
and get an air fryer so you can just
throw it in frozen it's so easy
it's so easy i've been using these guys
for three years all i eat is meat i'm
picky about my meat use code mp to get
free steak in your order at truelogo.ca
or twolocalusa.com
enjoy the rest of the episode okay so
that's a do you want to unpack we can
talk about the man body would you want
to unpack anything i've just said
yeah so so one thing you said um well no
just just a question after that is if
you're stuck in a so say a depressed way
of thinking where you get triggered by
something and you you immediately have a
flood of negative thoughts
how are you supposed to start like not
thinking that way because it sounds like
a be more positive or
not definitely not something so glad you
asked that question because this is
definitely not positive thinking i am
not a proponent of positive psychology i
think there's some good elements but
it's done a lot of damage because people
think that i can just slip on a positive
affirmation
the ideal is not to have those emotions
what i say is that
it's totally okay to be depressed in
fact it's so totally okay to be anxious
it's totally okay to experience any of
those give yourself permission yeah look
at them differently shift your
perspective and it's not a matter of i'd
mustn't think like that it's the white
very effectively
so we're not talking about that at all
this is a process of embracing embrace
as a messenger what my research showed
my most recent clinical trials which are
in that book plus there was a super
interesting study that came out of
tokyo and texas funnily enough um just
about a year ago talking about if we um
in the in the west we tend to look at
emotions like depression as bad things
but that's not what they are they're
actually incredibly helpful messengers
so if you look at them differently if
you say okay i am depressed i don't like
being depressed i'm feeling awful i
can't get out of bed this is terrible
i'm anxious i'm having whatever
acknowledge that it's horrible but don't
be scared of it don't think this is bad
or this is who i am or i've got a broken
brain or i'm stuck rather say okay this
makes me feel horrible but this is not
who i am it's a helpful messenger what
is it telling me the minute you do that
you shift 1400 neurophysiological
responses in your brain and your body to
work for you not against you now this is
what people aren't being told michaela
wait it's like the same
before yeah okay 1400 how did that
research come up these are how do they
know that that's not my reason i've done
a bit of that research so collectively
over the years there's been a lot of
research and this goes to other question
the mind brain body connection there's
about 150 years of research in the
modern scientific method of trying to
understand if we think in a certain way
why does it impact our body and how does
it impact our body and as of as our
techniques have advanced so we have
been able to see that if you are
totally not managing your stress your
cortisol levels will rise your
homocysteine levels all the things we
hear about so there's a direct link
that's been established very established
biomarkers for the mind brain body
connection i've done work on quite a few
of those and then also on things like
telomeres which are in your dna and that
kind of stuff and we see a very um i
showed my research this has also been
very it's pretty established research
that you can
you literally within seconds of you the
way you perceive a situation is going to
impact your these certain biomarkers
your dna and if you understand that by
shifting how your you can shift into two
minds at once we literally can have two
mindsets happening at the same time one
is the messy mind that's in that
depression or whatever and the other is
the wise mind that stands back and
observes your own thinking we can shift
into two we have the skill and when we
do that we get different kind of firing
in our brain and different interactions
between the different parts of the brain
and we move into high levels of
intelligence extremely high levels of
intelligence
and so literally we can stand back and
observe our own thinking feeling and
choosing in that state and so what we
want to do is say okay i am depressed so
why is mine he's literally talking to
messy mind saying okay you're depressed
that's fine that's okay it's what you're
going through it's how you're showing up
it's all right we're going to find the
reason there is a reason and when you
talk to yourself like that we're not
denying the situation which is the worst
thing you can do we're not saying
exactly you're not saying oh gosh think
positive thoughts that's the worst thing
you can do too because you're putting a
band-aid on a bullet when it's not going
to work what you're doing is you are
basically acknowledging and embracing
now we know from neuroscience the minute
that you acknowledge and embrace those
toxic thoughts that is creating the
sense of depression or whatever it is
panic attacks pain in your body
perspective i hate life whatever the
different cat the different signals
which we can talk about
then as soon as you say okay it's fine
then this talks this toxic tree
becomes uh it moves into the conscious
mind and the little branches that are
holding all the data become weakened and
when something's weakened it's malleable
it's changeable so alongside that which
is a whole lot of physiological
responses that changes the chemical
response in the brain so we now have an
increase of dopamine and an increase of
anandamide and it increases and so i can
go on that then changes the whole
hormone system everything changes the
endocrine system that then changes how
the heart's functioning so i can go on
so if you add it all up it's around
about 1400 neuro physiological brain
body responses that will occur in a
moment that will then shift you into
resilience as opposed to breakdown mode
and when you're in resilience mode you
can be sobbing screaming crying broken
lying on the floor but in in that moment
by saying to yourself this is okay it's
okay get it out it's fine you're
shifting your physiology which then
gives you the strength to then start
climbing up and doing the deconstruction
reconstruction process and that's the
part that it's it's not easy but that's
what you can that's what you can train
yourself to do because that's what you
actually um how your physiology works
okay that is fascinating so
um just just a brief background on like
what i went through i was on
antidepressants really high dosage of
ciprelax for like 12 years or 13 years
and
yeah me too
and i
fixed my diet and my depression went
away and i stopped taking my
antidepressants over a period of two
weeks because i didn't realize
withdrawal
i didn't realize that was the thing and
then for about two and a half years i
had like horrible
um depression but i was aware
that it had something to do with the
medication because i was like this is so
awful it can't be real so one of the
things i did during that time was
when i had these they were triggered by
like carby carbier foods and the
withdrawal would get worse which is
something i now know looking back on it
but um i'd separate and think okay this
is happening to me but it's so awful it
can't be me
so like it's a reaction that's happening
yes but um
but it's but it's got to go away because
it's so crazily bad that i must be able
to heal from this right and that's kind
of what i thought and and eventually i
healed and it's gone wow so that's kind
of crazy to hear because it's i didn't
realize that
you actually did the science you
actually applied instinctively
what i've been teaching what i've just
explained to you and what i've been
researching all these years you you are
one of the few that's managed to
actually do that because it's not many
people i mean there's more than a
million survivor sites of people that
have got off antidepressants and if
you've kind of gone the journey that
you've gone and i mean as you and i both
said before this shouldn't even be
happening in the first place but yes
um but yeah you so you what you quite
right there withdrawal when you take an
antidepressant it basically changes the
structures of your brain and you
probably know this but at the point
where these things the trees that you
build they all connected to each other
and at the point of connection all the
little branches where they connect to me
they touch other neurons um it's called
the synapse we get a little little
doorways and the doorways increase and
they're abnormal increases so you're
putting too many doors little doors in
your brain so that disrupts balance and
flow and so the the thing that
antidepressant even the word is is scary
to use because it's not correct it
implies that it's like an
antibiotic fixing getting rid of
bacteria it's not fixing anything all
it's doing is numbing those doorways
create a numbing effect in the brain but
the problem is that it's an abnormal
structure so then the brain starts
battling with that so it has all those
side effects and i'm sure you know about
them but there's just so many bad side
effects fortunately for neuroplasticity
you your brain is healing so yes your
brain did get damaged but you through
your diet exercise your your mindset
you've not used that first cause of mind
to actually drive healing into your
brain
and you know so yours is a great story
that you've come out the other side and
you've managed to survive with the
withdrawal and that kind of thing but
that's withdrawal people need to taper
if people make the decision you've got a
taper and you've got to
you've got to do diet and exercise but
you also have to do mine because you can
taper and you die and exercise but if
you don't get your mind right
if you don't have a way of managing your
mind that will throw you off because
mind is the biggest force mind drives
everything without mind you there's
nothing the diet doesn't mind drives
diet i mean to the point michelle i
don't if you're aware of this but if you
eating and you're eating a super healthy
diet which i know you're very into
eating healthy but if your mind is like
all worked up and worried about
something
eating you lose up to 86 percent of the
nutrition so i mean our minds driving
that digestive system the assimilation
of nutrients the pancreas the
gallbladder all of it's been driven by
mind so we we don't realize that mind
being first caused we should be teaching
mind to our kids in schools as lessons i
did this when i was working in education
systems and that's when i do still
lessons there should be lessons at
school we should be teaching our kids
from babies we should never stop
learning about how to manage our mind
because mind messy mind messy brain
messy body messy life no matter how many
books you read or how many podcasts you
listen to it's still
okay so how do you
like you must come across people who've
been in
science for a long time and who are
saying this isn't real there's so
how do you how do you start how do you
convince somebody that mind
or anything like mindset actually makes
a difference because even i didn't
believe that right i started the diet
and then it just
i just i had that mindset it wasn't
something i worked on it just popped in
thank goodness uh so it wasn't something
it was something i kind of took for
granted and i didn't realize how
powerful it could be until i started
having some meals where i was horribly
stressed like serious family illness
horribly stressed and i'd get kind of
sick after and i was like how it's the
same thing i was eating before
i was like really like oh no how much of
this is in my head which is good
actually because if you're good because
it means you can control it but exactly
exactly
how do you talk to somebody about that
and convince them that that actually
matters
well let's put it this way
some of the main science top in top
universities across the globe are and
have been not
not just but have for a long time been
showing this evidence of mind brain and
the impact of our thought life on our
physical body so when someone says it's
not real if a scientist is not real they
really aren't up to date with research
that's the first thing i wouldn't say
that to them because they would get you
know it's an aggressive kind of
statement but just for you and i to know
that some of the top scientists are like
you'll get top scientists at harvard and
mit and you know all the the ivy leagues
that aren't that won't even talk about
um psychotropics they'll say that those
are dangerous say that you don't use
them that's just it's you never you that
mind brain connection is real you know
they added to one side the other side is
the language that's used so like
scientists that say that the brain does
everything look at the research and i'll
give you a synopsis but they'll take
people they'll put them into a lab
they'll tell them to do something or
think about something or they'll show
them pictures in other words they're
taking an alive person and they're
making them think about something i say
okay think of a sad story or look at the
sad picture or so they tell them to do
something in other words they get them
thinking and feeling and choosing and
then they measure their brain or they
look at their brain using fmri or they
do various different things to test it
so
so they're saying that the brain
produces the depression meanwhile they
ask the person to do something that made
them have a depression response and they
measure the response in the brain so
it's language it's how they're looking
at it does that make sense they are
saying the person in the lab is
depressed because their brain is broken
they're looking for the neurobiological
correlate but they didn't just put the
person in that in the lab they gave the
person something to think about first
the first was mind and action then was
response in brain so they looked at the
response in the brain to the person
thinking even if they didn't tell the
person to think of anything just being
in a lab with an fmri
on you you're going to go into an fmri
you're going to be anxious so they're
going to pick up anxiety in the anxiety
response in the brain in other words
take a dead person stick them in the
fmri machine you won't get response so
that's one of my first things i'll say
to them the other thing is there is such
a body of literature i've done i
mentioned earlier on i've done work in
looking at let's talk let's talk about
telomeres it's probably one of the most
convincing ways of telling helping
people that would be good
and telomeres there's been a lot of
research on telomeres in relation to
food and diet and exercise and lifestyle
but not a huge amount on um on the
directly on mind mind drives lifestyle i
mean you know yourself you had to use
your mind you had to make a decision to
change your diet you you used your mind
in all your descriptions earlier on you
said i recognized that i was eating a
meal made me feel sick this couldn't be
right because this food didn't make me
sick before i recognized i was in a
stressful situation all of that you you
were using your mind you were thinking
feeling and choosing about your
situation so you used your mind to
analyze the mind brain response so you
looked at your own body
and you looked at your mental state you
put two and two together ah boom it's my
mind so you did that very you did
research without even knowing you were
doing research and you came to the
conclusion and changed that was all
mind-driven okay so
here's the telomere thing telomeres are
the the if you think of a chromosome a
chromosome you think of the dna strand
everyone can visualize that and if you
pull out a chromosome it looks like an x
so i'm going to cross my fingers so
anyone listening watching they can cross
their fingers or whatever and my
fingernails which are conveniently
painted pink at the moment are let's
pretend they're telomeres telomeres are
the ends of chromosomes telomeres do a
lot of stuff nothing in the body works
in isolation everything works together
but we're going to just talk about in
terms of one of the main functions at
the moment telomeres are a proxy for
mind health so how you are actually
managing your mind in the moment so in
other words if you are
going through a stressful situation you
eat that meal in that moment your mind
would have been affecting your telomeres
this is how significant it is we make
about a million new cells every second
the quality of those those cells they
make up your digestive system your brain
your body so over time we are rebuilding
every system of our body with our mind
driving the cells so if you think you're
making about a million cells plus every
second the quality of those cells is
determined by the quality of your mind
management in the moment and that hits
your telomere so the telomere is
involved in helping to make the cells
the telomeres are reliant on the energy
from the mind which comes with an
electromagnetic force and a
neurochemical force which then impacts
the telomeres and activates the
telomeres
sorry i'm
i've got this weird combination of being
extremely open and extremely skeptical
when i got the skepticisms from my dad
the openness is from my mom but it's
very good how do they know that the mind
i believe it but how do they know it how
do they know that the mind is impacting
the telomere like length
yes so what i showed in my study and i
can tell you directly from my study and
actually i've got graphs in the book and
things
so the telomere um
the strength of the telomere they can
they can fray like a shoelace so if you
and they've done a lot of research
showing that people with very poor diets
they've got very we can tell them here
so they do blood work you take a blood
sample and you then they've got these
incredible ways of analyzing the
functionality of that of the telomere so
they look at telomere length they look
at 10 and more percent there's different
ways that they can you can look at the
telomeres and then from there what
you've obviously got um we know that if
it's a healthy cell the telomeres is you
want an ideal sort of length an ideal
sort of strength so that when it when
when you they and they keep staying like
a long strong fingernail for example but
if your fingernails keep breaking and
peeling and chipping and and getting
worse and worse over time you may not
even have a nail eventually so they've
so they've been able to through blood
work and through studying the telomeres
um in different circumstances they can
track and see so people that have had
extremely bad diets exercise lifestyle
and stress because you very when someone
has a poor lifestyle they're not
managing their stress either so they
always say stress is one off but stress
is the mind is driving all of it mind is
driving the choice of to what to eat how
to exercise and also how you are dealing
with the day-to-day stuff plus the big
stuff in your life that you haven't
dealt with the traumas the past issues
etc etc so they see and i saw this in my
research i had for example some subjects
that came into into this we did a double
blind study by the way so random control
double blind all that all the good stuff
all the gold standard and some of the
subjects came in well they all came in a
wreck everyone's pretty much all of us
all mess all the time but we just go to
men it's how we're managing our mess and
that's totally okay that's it's okay to
be a mess that's really fundamental to
my teaching it's be a mess just manage
it um so for example one of the case
studies was a more or less 30 year old
and a mid-30s millennial and
came in saying i am depression i
and the narrative was just like a mess
their blood work was a mess high
cortisol high homosystem yeah
the whole these all the psychological
tools were terrible and the narrative
the most important thing was their story
what is going on in your life what's
happening it was like a mess the
telomere length in that particular
person was really bad
and telomere length is interesting
because it tells you about the cells and
cells group to form the body and so it
tells us you tells us about the health
of your biology of your actual body so
from a telomere you can you can make a
judgment on a person's biological age
and so
even this particular person's biological
age was 35 plus years older than the
actual chronological age and it was a
sickly older so if you're in your 30s
and you have a body of a sickly 65 year
old
your vulnerability to disease has
increased by a factor of up to 60 70
percent if not more and if it doesn't
get treated you're going to constantly
because it aggregates and accumulates so
the research explains it like from the
research we can say this that if we
don't manage our minds and therefore
manage how we're dealing with the
triggers and things in our life and the
traumas we are increasing our
vulnerability
to disease
okay by these factors that accumulate
over time so it's not i think a bad
thought i get cancer that's ridiculous
it's not i think a good thought the
cancer goes away which is as ridiculous
which is you know the law of attraction
positive thinking you've got to be so
careful of those things because that in
itself can bring tremendous guilt to
people
it's cycles of 63 days i've had some
patients that went through two years of
cycles or 63 days because there were so
many elements to their trauma that they
didn't fix it in one cycle so if but
every time that you are fixing a cycle
every time you are managing your mind
recognize as you recognize this food is
affecting me in this way you were
shifting the energy that was the energy
flow the electromagnetic flow through
your brain through your body through
your blood the neurochemistry the flow
all of that was shifting which then
influenced your telomeres so your
telomeres started being able to heal so
the cells not in one day but over time
over the two year three year four year
period have been getting stronger and
stronger so your health has been coming
back
you know the same thing will happen with
your dad too and with anyone who is in
under any kind of eventually over time
and not everything and not saying
everything's gonna get fixed and go away
we're going to be often
with collateral damage meaning
sometimes it's so different michaela for
everyone there is no cookie cutter if
you do this all i know
is that we saw within nine weeks three
cycles of that 63 days three cycles of
21 days that the subjects in our control
in our experimental group that got the
treatment they did the mind management
they're telling me as lengthened and
strengthened so by the nine week point
that person that i described in the
beginning that 30 year old their
chronological and biological age matched
in other words their they were no longer
sitting after nine weeks with a 65 year
old sickly body they were sitting with a
body that was actually closer in age to
the chronological age their cortisol had
dropped their homocysteine levels to
drop which meant that inflammation in
their brain and body can significantly
drop which meant that their heart and
brain would no longer extreme risk for
various different things to go wrong i
mean that's just a couple of things so
yeah there's more and more research
being done in this area and the reason i
do
when i do research i look at the
psychological and the narrative and the
blood and the dna and the brain i look
at so many elements which is kind of
unusual because research normally looks
at just an fmri or just cortisol i put
them together because you've got to look
at people holistically and you've got to
see what what is the whole pattern
that's going on in a person's life you
know and and there you can see that that
driving force so that particular person
which really kind of sums this whole
thing up in day one they were saying i
am depression their identity was
depression their mind and body were a
mess homocysteine up inflammation
telomeres biological all the things i've
described by day 21 they were saying
i'm not depression can't be depression
it's not my identity i feel depressed
because of radical difference
but i feel then they also said this
always fascinated me
they said i feel i actually feel more
depressed and more anxious but it's
different
it's actually helpful i'm seeing i'm
feeling more depressed because now this
person had had terrible abuse as a child
and had never faced it it had been
suppressed and this um treatment the
inter entering into the protocol into
the into the clinical study had given
her
a subject a way of unpacking
and so the sadness and depression came
from oh my gosh that happened to me when
you start seeing stuff that happened to
you yeah as a child i mean it's
traumatic so there was another level of
trauma but by day 63 this person was
saying okay i accepted this happened to
me i can't change that it happened but i
can change how i manage it it's not
going to control me the rest of my life
i'm going to get back their life and
that's i mean that's a big summary of
the whole thing obviously the detail i
don't share but the big picture i do
that particular subject is in this book
as a case study which gives people so
much hope and that's why i do this
research because i want people to see
that yes every thought you think is
having an impact you're always thinking
and and you can either stay messy which
is just going to make you really
frustrated or you can own your mess
and change and change it because if you
through mess we can repair we can grow
it's so okay to be messy as long as
we're managing it so that's kind of the
philosophy that's insane
so through through mind management you
measured people's telomeres laying and
you could
increase it that is insane was there
anything else was anything else changed
like did you also change diet did you
incorporate exercise or what it was just
yes that is one
variable so because there's so much work
done on exercise and i do i mean i talk
about that all the time i write books
about it it's so important but i can put
you on a great diet if i don't get your
mind help you get your mind right you're
not going to get the same benefit so we
didn't touch that in the study we do
more studies and we'll we'll bring that
but i wanted to get the mind managed i
wanted to show people
mind is first course so we can get a
handle on that and give ourselves
permission to be sad and depressed and
angry and frustrated and and and get it
out if it doesn't go out it goes any we
can do that and then recognize okay i've
got to go beyond just awareness i've got
to get it out i've got to be aware i've
got to go beyond what we're doing
currently in this current day and age
and i'm just talking very generally but
in the wellness industry you very well
burst in this area is that and it's not
wrong that people are okay let's
meditate let's breathe yes let's do that
but that only prepares your brain so
you'll see in the systems that i've
developed you do brain preparation and
then you go beyond so you do brain
preparation is your breathing your
meditation you're having all those
beautiful things that are vital to get
neurochemistry and stuff under control
but they're not enough the research
shows if i just create awareness in you
it's going to make you worse and and i
showed that in my control group because
yeah we had a control group and i've got
that study in here too of the one of the
case studies and one of the subjects who
same sort of age as the one i just
described but they didn't get the
treatment so that they got all the
testing so they were super aware of all
the issues because they kept getting
asked all these questions
and having contact with people but they
got worse and worse and worse and worse
eventually got what we call a red brain
which was such high levels of anxiety
that they were in a dangerous position
obviously we gave them the treatment
ethically we did with all of the
subjects in the control group they all
got the treatment because it was
randomized um and and that there was a
change almost immediately i mean it was
phenomenal so awareness alone and this
is what we see
in the literature too that people that
if you just meditate you bring stuff up
but what are you going to do with it you
have to deconstruct it so people
meditate stuff comes up and then they
shove it down you can't breathe it away
you can't meditate it away you meditate
and breathe to
get resilience in your brain and your
body to help get your alpha levels going
so you can connect an unconscious and
conscious but now you've got to do work
this ugly thing has to be deconstructed
you have to find the root and you have
to change it make it work for you and
not against you
okay so how do you do that
i knew that question was coming good
question okay so i wanted to know how to
do this 38 years ago because i was told
as a therapist just teach your patients
to compensate teach them techniques so
techniques are not going to work they're
going to work yes in the right place so
cbt act all these
you know there's a million techniques
out there that therapists have and that
you can see and you can google and find
them and find books and but techniques
alone don't solve the problem so i
wanted to get to the basics okay how
does the thought form how do these
thoughts form what are memories what
what am i doing to grow this and then if
i go how do i get rid of it yeah yeah
i wanted to know
yeah so i wanted and wanted to also know
how to find them how do i know when i've
got these yeah what do they look like
what are the signs that i've got this
and how to deal with it because in any
one i mean you know i could just
brainstorm now and actually i'll come up
with at least 10 things i need to work
on that of that that are upsetting me at
the moment and definitely if i don't
manage or impair my functioning i'm sure
you could so it's normal
yeah that's good that's really being
human that's great but what we need to
do is say okay well these are the things
happening let's be thought detectives
and let's say okay which is the top one
that's number one that's my priority
this thing's really affecting i'm going
to deal with those later so you select
your top priority and then you start
analyzing so you start with so this is
the
choose the make a list
choose the top one i'm just giving you a
quick rundown detail in here and i also
have an app i don't know if you're aware
i haven't actually talked about the app
too the neuro cycle app which walks you
it's like me giving you therapy
literally okay so first of all um you
make the decision to look at your
patterns choose the top one then what
you do is you start second thing is you
start things saying okay what let me
break my pattern down
first of all what are my emotions
what are my behaviors
what are my body symptoms and what about
what is my perspective
the way the easiest way to do this is
many ways but one of the ways i would do
with my patients is i would say get two
chairs
and use it in one and you're also in the
other one in the one that you physically
are that's the messy mind or whatever
and then the other one is the wise mind
what is the wise mind the wise mind is
what we see in
neurobiology is that you have no wiring
in your brain and body for
anything toxic so we don't have
depression in here wired waiting to jump
out we don't have anger we don't have
anything we don't have none of that's in
the brain the brain people still believe
that right they have a deficiency a
serotonin deficiency or they have some
yeah some kind of brain disease because
that's the language that's used that's
what people are told take the drugs
you've got a brain disease it'll fix
your drug don't give people stigmatize
you mean while the research has shown
that that stigmatized people more and i
don't know if you're aware of this
research and i put it in my book too but
that approach has increased people's
deaths um shorten people's life lifespan
so between 1996 and 2014 a massive
series of studies was done where they
found that for decades we've been living
longer obviously because of advances in
medicine and technology but that
reversed it started reversing in 96 by
2014 it was an established reversal it's
called death
categorizes deaths of despair so
essentially people are dying eight to 25
years younger and they should now in
this modern age
it's two years added to this with a
pandemic
from preventable lifestyle issues so
people dying younger and gen
is the most medicated generation ever in
history and they are the most risk of
dying 80 to 25 years younger which is
terrible and it's all fault as adults as
as leaders as whatever because our
generation has adopted the last 40 years
has has totally messed this up we're
sitting not with a pandemic in mental
health we're sitting with a pandemic
result of mismanagement of mental health
we've had total mismanagement and your
story your dad's story and the millions
of stories that i read and i get
thousands of emails a week of people
that have had the same story and that's
why i'm so passionate about getting this
out there so essentially what the first
thing i want people to do is to say
please give yourself permission it's
okay whatever you've experienced and
whatever you're experiencing you at your
core are wired for love you're amazing
and that's not just me being
motivational i'm not a motivational
speaker i'm a realist i'm a scientist
your neurobiology is phenomenal you have
all these systems in place to fight like
if you have the covert virus still the
immune system goes crazy and tries to
find it if you have a toxic trauma in
your life as i mentioned earlier your
immune system will do the same thing it
will also send out t lymphocytes and b
lymphocytes and macrophages to go eat
this thing to go get rid of it but if
you if the source is not if the source
keeps it there which is your mind your
mind is the source
um it keeps it there then then no amount
of immune help is going it's just going
to become extra inflamed and you're
going to get an autoimmune response and
a body and a body response there so what
we want to do is we want to listen to
the signals of the immune system
which will affect our body's functioning
and we want to listen to the immune
signals of our so the thematic
sensations in our body we want to listen
to the signals of of our emotions and
the signals of our behaviors so
having said all of that start with the
core premise that you're amazing that
you're brilliant that you wired for love
and however you showing up is because of
adverse circumstances that have
aggregated and accumulated and you slid
down the scale i always use the scale
zero to ten and zero to minus ten and
the average is minus forty plus four and
in any one day we have good and bad
stuff happening but generally we can
kind of manage and that's all cool so
it's totally fine it's when it
aggregates and we start sitting around
the minus four area and then it shifts
down minus five minus six so and so on
into extreme states and that's when
people get completely stuck and that's
when people get labeled with all these
labels now the research shows that as
soon as you get a label you've just
chopped off up to another that's the
25-year end without a label you're in
the eight-year end of dying earlier with
a label a mental health label you've
just pushed yourself into the potential
25-year
younger death so you die maybe 65
instead of 85 or something like that and
it's preventable so i'm so hot on not
telling people this so people can get
out of that because you can you can get
out of that you don't have to be stuck
in that it's not a death sentence so we
get away we move on okay so let's give
yourself permission so it's basically
look at the pattern with those four
areas which is the emotions behaviors
what am i feeling depression what am i
what are my behaviors i'm more withdrawn
than normal crying more than normal
nothing wrong with crying but if your
crying pattern has changed if anything's
changed that's what you're looking at
body what's going on in your body
there's so much about body and heart
trauma stored in the body it is stood in
the body you've got to look at your body
you're listening to me now you're not
only building a healthy thought in your
brain of the stuff but you also as soon
as it's in your brain your brain sends a
message to every cell of your body
you've got 37 to 100 trillion and you've
changed your dna so your genes are
building this this memories in your
brain as a tree and it's in your body in
your genes in every single cell of your
body your memories form it's not
mind-blowing to think of so it's in your
body that's why people experience trauma
in their body and with mdr and those
kind of things pull it out of the body
into the brain into the mind there's the
third place that memories or thoughts
are stored within memories is in the
mind now think of this podcast if you
look at the little bars at the bottom
you'll see little bars running if you're
watching the podcast you know you know
the little bars i'm talking about
that's a visual for mine mind is a
gravitational field around you and
through you it's an electromagnetic
field so memory is also stored all
around you you've got your memories in
these fields
and in your brain as a tree and in your
body so it's in three places so that's
why it's such a holistic experience when
you have a trauma and we recall it and
you go through a traumatic event and
you're building all of that into you so
you're experiencing it with all of you
so we have to address all of you so you
have to then say okay what is going on
let me be the thought detective let me
look at my body
increased gi issues
increased um maybe
heart palpitations whatever what are the
body signs what are the as i said
emotions what are the behavior changes
and then perspective that's massive how
am i looking at life
am i seeing it life sucks why am i
thinking this always happens to me that
your overarching perspective that is
activated when you think of this
particular pattern is very important
because it's the it'll lead you to your
trauma response your coping mechanism
the type of trauma are you in flight
flight freeze yeah it leads to those
kind of things so you look at those and
i walk you through this whole process in
depth in my app called neurocycle and in
the book then you start then you then
you literally say okay
i've got the pattern i've started seeing
these different areas now i'm going to
start unpacking them but before you do
that you now just need to give yourself
a little bit of brain boosting
resilience and that's where you can
meditate you can breathe you can i know
your dad did one move i've interviewed
him too and he didn't like that and a
lot of people battle when you breathe
and get into meditative states if you've
got trauma it can make you freak out so
you can do yeah your eyes opening you
can do havening and tapping so i
recommend my highly traumatized patients
i used to just do let's just do some
tapping because then you keep your eyes
open don't you know anything just to
lower the neurochemistry what does that
could do
it seems a um when you tap like that or
give yourself a hug that creates a um it
seems as a very strong sense of it's
basically like an alpha wave through
your brain and your body up into your
amygdala and then um your amygdala is a
library and like libraries have got
books with information there's books
with good information about i can do
this and these books this is terrible
life sucks yeah and if we if our
amygdala is stimulated incorrectly the
life sucks box hits you on the head but
if you tap or breathe or any one of
those brain preparation you actually
close that part of the library and you
open the other part that says oh maybe i
can do this so that's a simple
explanation it does a bunch of other
stuff too but it sends a very calming
wave to the amygdala which enables us to
get that neurochemistry and that um
you don't want the high beta flowing
through the amygdala and it will be in a
panic state so you want to just get the
beta down so what i do in brain
preparation is you choose whatever
technique and in the app i have a three
minute little technique every day and
you can try that or try your own and
we're building a whole lot more into the
app so you can just choose whatever you
want to do then you start with the
actual mirror cycle
so the neurocycle was developed i
developed it 38 years ago with my tbi
patients my alzheimer's dementia all
those patients learning disability
i've developed a theory so this is very
scientific and then i wanted a practical
application because patients aren't
interested in theories they're
interested in what do i do and so i
wanted to find the actual steps so all
the stuff i'm talking about all these
thoughts brain how the thoughts form
order that i i wanted to work out if i
do this what's happening in the brain if
i do this what's happening in the brain
so in the book i've got a chart where i
explain the five steps in detail with
what's happening in the mind brain and
body but you've got to set the neuro
cycle up which after six play acceptance
look at the pattern do the breathing or
tapping or whatever and then you start
the neurocycle before i explain the five
steps you do it for a limited amount of
time if you're working on a hectic
trauma or a really the thing that is
hard for you in your life you spend 15
to 45 minutes yeah
okay important yeah that's so important
so you can do this in as quick as seven
minutes because it's five steps the
brain preparation i always recommend
like one two three two or three minutes
or so so if you can block off 15 to 45
minutes once a day for 63 days i know it
sounds a lot but here's my argument your
minds are messy anyway so if you all
you're doing is using your mind i'm not
saying you i'm saying all of us if
you've got a trauma your mind's working
anyway so you may as well work it in the
direction you want this is direct to
neuroplasticity so it's an organized
technique that you do for 15 to 45
minutes for 21 days the second phase of
42 days the other two cycles of 21 you
only take five minutes so it's not a lot
to do and when you get into this it's so
life-saving that pattern that that's
dominating your functioning at the
moment is certainly not going to be
dominating your functioning because
you're allocating a 15 to 45 minute
block once a day to deal with it so the
rest of the day you can actually be set
free from that because you're not going
to think of it the rest of the day
you're going to work on it tomorrow
morning or whenever you choose your time
so and then that process one of the
biggest problems with therapy and
intervention and counseling and coaching
is what we call carryover carryovers do
great in therapy with your therapist but
when you leave therapy it's kind of hard
to always apply that so carryover is
always a big challenge and so i wanted
to bring that and i did a lot of
research in how do you train someone to
do something help them in therapy or
help them on their own but they carry
that over into the day so the neurocycle
is a way of thinking that you can use in
this very almost self-therapy sense you
can use in therapy you have a lot of
therapists that use it we have a
coaching course and everything um and
you can use on your own because if
you're not you're not with your
therapist every day you're with your
therapist maybe once or twice a week or
counselor or coach you live with
yourself you're waking up with yourself
at night and your mind's going crazy you
need mind management 24 7. so this neuro
cycle provides you with a way of doing
therapy a way of doing your daily
therapy with yourself the serious stuff
and then it's also a way of catching
yourself when you have chaos during the
day and you mentioned that early on what
happens if all these thoughts are like
this what do i do your neurocycle so
it's a way of catching stuff and then
unpacking it getting it in order and
getting control and you're using your
wise mind your neurobiology that's wired
for survival your survival mind kicks in
as soon as you say okay this is okay i'm
aware of this i'm going to gather and as
you so as soon as you do the thing i've
just said your wise mind takes over your
neurobiology changes those 1400
neurophysiological responses kick in and
you start being able to get control you
get agency and as the more you do this
the more you get empowered so over time
i showed in a nine week period my
patients my subjects my clinical trial
this has happened for years because i've
been working on this for years it was an
81
ability to increase 81
agency increased by 81
which meant that my mind's chaos i can't
do this
i've got 81 more power to get this under
control versus zero power or 10 power
which is oh my day's a mess and it just
gets worse does that make sense
that is
that's insane
that is so cool like that is so cool
yeah i've been
i just finished um i've been writing a
book and i've been writing a book for
since i was like in grade one because
that was part of the way i handled bad
things that were happening because i
wrote them down so i've turned it into a
book i finally finished the book but um
it was horrible it was absolutely
horrible to write because everything i
was writing
was just i had to relive it it made me
cry but then i felt better after but i
did that
you deconstructed it yeah and i do i do
exercise first so i was able to write
and then i'd work and i'd only work for
up to 45 minutes
because
i couldn't tolerate i couldn't tolerate
more i noticed if i did like two hours i
was just wiped for three or four days
and i'd like cry a bunch the whole time
it got easier but at the beginning it
was just like sobbing and then i
finished it's so hard but yeah that's
it's so interesting to learn some of the
actual science behind what these things
are doing because i was just like i
don't know why this is making me feel
better but it's working there you go you
you describe what that that subjects
described where they said they got worse
they were more depressed and sad but it
was different because they were seeing
the pain so you were processing through
the brains the treatment effect you
always see i always warn my patients you
get bit worse before you get better you
know that's just inevitable but you
people aren't always prepared for that
because people think if i'm people can
go into feel that it's bad yeah people
can go from extreme anxiety
non-functional
functional and then into deep depression
as they start seeing and then people
think you've gone backwards you haven't
gone backwards that's progress because
that deep depression is evidence of you
just trying to manage what you've found
so you're crying your tears that was
your your just sadness and getting it
out and it's been there for so many
years and processing and getting it out
so that's so and we've got it that's
what we've got to do we've got to level
the playing fields so you actually went
through all these processes i've just
taken what we are you see you prove
wired for love you proved that you have
an optimism bias you prove that mind is
first cause everything you've gone
through all i've done is the science of
behind what you've actually experienced
so this is i'm talking about the science
of a basic human
philosophy how we function
and
basically putting it into systems so
that the neuro cycle you pretty much did
as you sat down and wrote you first
gathered awareness of your thoughts for
the day
and you would have got there was you
know the pattern all those things you
may not have distinctly done the
behavior emotion in that order but you
would well actually
here's here's where it gets weirder okay
so that was finishing my book my book
was like that was more recent that's
when i'm doing my i'm much healthier it
was a lot easier it was still emotional
but it was easier when i was actually in
the healing period when i was
when i'd stopped taking the medications
and i was in ssri withdrawal i spent
time each day monitoring how i was like
studying myself because it was the only
way i stayed sane i was like what are my
digestive symptoms what's my mood i had
a scale from zero to ten zero being the
worst
yeah that's so weird but mine was zero
to ten so not negative ten plus ten and
i put down all my i put down like every
symptom i could think of three times a
day
for like two and a half years so that i
could monitor the patterns wow that's
phenomenal you i mean you did a whole
research study there you should put that
in your book too i mean that's really
incredibly brilliant because that is
what that's mind management you've just
demonstrated the principles of mind
management because the neuro cycles
literally gather awareness then reflect
on them which is ask once to discuss it
write them down i've developed a
technique called metacogging which is
something you'd love when you learn how
to do it it's in the book
and the app and it's a way of writing
that forces the two sides of the brain
to work together and digs deep into your
get your intuitive skills like boosted
so yeah into your into your unconscious
like oh my i used to do this with a lot
with my patients that were backing with
you know schizophrenic symptoms yeah and
like multiple personalities and like
severe trauma where they were
non-functional i would actually teach
them to learn using the neurocycle so
they would learn educational stuff
because that builds resilience and then
i'd work on the heavy stuff and because
it got the brain set up for um
or being able to and and deal with the
the shock of trauma and the emotions and
that kind of thing and we would i would
using the metacog within the neurocycle
because it's step three of the
neurocycle i would help them they would
basically be writing all over this paper
and they would be i'd say tell me how
you're feeling or something or what's
going on or what's what's this and they
would have five different versions but
they'd never seen that then they
suddenly saw it in this format and they
said oh five different personalities and
each one came from a level of trauma
going back to the inner child and all
that so i'm saying this this new cycle
that i'm talking about this is like it's
come from heavy heavy research and
application and it's so i've simplified
it so much that anyone a child can do
this but it's doing the most phenomenal
stuff in your brain and then the fourth
step is also where you the that writing
step that third step is kind of chaos
it's just like you're you're kind of
dragging all the stuff out of the nut
you're just dumping it then recheck is
where you go and like sorted out what
are the patterns and triggers and
antidotes and you reconceptualize and
reconceptualizing is
accepting that okay this happened but it
doesn't i can change this i can see it
differently so instead of for example oh
everyone always leaves me i can't keep a
relationship going it's not no
everyone's always leaving you we
conceptualize that is that you're always
trying to make it work so you always try
and stay because you're trying to make
it work that's the reconceptualization
it's another perspective and it's only
when we started
which takes the first few steps to get
to that point that you can start
shifting and moving forward and in the
fourth step the first step is a little
action that you do to keep you in a safe
space during the day that's got various
components to it i mean that's just a
very brief overview and it's like super
clear in the book and in the app where i
literally walk you through it and the
app we growing all the time and we're
building in a neuro cycle lab where
people can bring their problems and we
can talk through and work through how to
do it so yeah lots of things happening
that is so cool i've been working on an
app with my dad for resilience
where it helps you identify factors in
your life that you're upset with and
then identify what exactly you're upset
with and then this is simplified but
basically make to-do lists in order to
slowly chip away at the problems in your
life
wonderful hopefully that'll help people
okay
our time is up i cannot recommend this
enough that was absolutely brilliant
i'm
a bit shocked that's so cool i didn't
realize that there was actual
research out on this stuff because it's
so complicated like suggesting that the
mind is separate from the brain even
that's not how i was brought up at all
that's not what i learned uh so
that's incredible and i hopefully that
gives people
a lot of hope
so thank you very much if people aren't
following you um where can they find you
online dr caroline leaf my social media
handle so they can find me and then from
as you know from instagram you can find
everything my web page i have a podcast
called cleaning up the medical mess i
need to have you on you need to talk
through your what do you do
yeah no we need mine too no but just the
way you describe it it'll be very
helpful for people but young people can
find out what tons of information
carolina is probably the best place to
go first because suddenly as i said you
get to everything
okay great thank you very much for
coming on oh thank you i enjoyed it
thank you there's great questions
[Music]
you